[Music]
20:20 has been a rough year so far
hasn't it if you're someone who's in the
slightest bothered about the news and
such I'm sure you'd agree luckily not
everything is doom and gloom if you're
feeling down and under the weather
because of all of the things happening
or personally wearing down on you maybe
sitting back and unwinding with a couple
of anime will do the trick
in such a medium it's easy to find one
that will tickle your funny bones and
perhaps tell you that the world isn't so
bad after all I don't know if I'd
consider rom-com anime is healing anime
but they sure help you unwind and relax
after a stressful day at work so for
this video I present ten titles that you
might want to take a look at if you're a
fan of the good old rom-com and want
some laughs here and there
[Music]
who could forget the good old days when
this ago was the talk of the town
no there may be you consider the wife
Awards and how it turned the community
upside down if so then you probably need
no introduction to the story of rock ooh
Rock ooh ichijou heir to the yakuza
dreams of nothing but living an ordinary
life as fate would have it life for him
is nothing close to ordinary in addition
to having vague memories of a girl whom
he made a promise to he also runs into
Jethro gay The Beehive gangs err in
order to prevent an all-out gang war
between the Beehive and the Yakuza the
two are forced into pretending to be
lovers the problem Rocco has the hots
for another girl
the demure Onodera who seems to be a
really suspicious candidate of the
promise girl from rock whose memories
well what do you know must be tough
being rock ooh ha
[Music]
at least Rocco's relationship doesn't
involve constant torment at the hands of
a smug girl too smart for her own good
for once we have a protagonist that
doesn't dream of living an ordinary life
free from his past or family obligations
instead nishikawa's deepest desire is to
get back at his seat mate in daily
tormentor takagi for years our porn
protagonists been at the mercy of his
seat mate who teases him daily revenge
would be oh so sweet
that is if Nishikawa can actually find a
way to make his hits land I mean for
everything he's tried the gargy seems to
find a way to turn the odds against him
and end up teasing him even more luckily
for them none of that rains on the
cicadas parade as he's even more intent
on exacting revenge one day don't worry
miss Agartha someday you'll get her
someday
on another note they do say that teasing
is the first sign of love so
[Music]
coming in at number eight is saikhan oh
and about you but when I was a school I
once dreamt of being a game developer
something could have struck you and
inspired you to get going
despite game dev being an audacious goal
for most people from otaku protagonists
Amoy hockey that spark comes from a
fateful encounter with a girl determined
to make a game featuring her the Moya
recruits his school's top creators
artists Sawamura and novelist with aha
for his project of course things aren't
as easy as they seem and to compound to
the rough start of the project the Moya
finds out that the girl he idolized is
none other than Magoo MacArthur his
boring classmate for those attuned to
otaku culture and with an interest in
the creation process of media psycho
knows a really fun watch it may not be
shirobako or girlish number but the
humor endearing characters and character
dynamics do their job in carrying this
show beyond my initial expectations with
the movie having just come out to wrap
the series up now's the best time to
pick the show up and watch you all the
way to its conclusion
[Music]
next is a love juni Bo and other
delusions ah good old middle-school
syndrome I'm sure lot of us had it to
some degree when we were young it's not
like we can help it is it it's fun to
imagine ourselves as the master magic
wielder who has the link to the
everlasting cycle of rebirth it's like
playing a personal D&D before its
current popularity and - society's
approval or at least tolerance of said
antics you'd thought oh gosh she's
exactly the hero who could sympathize
with us like most he's since abandoned
that lifestyle pursuing a life as far
away from his previous self as possible
with only some cringes at the guy he
once was unfortunately his past ghosts
keep knocking at his door as he meets
Rika Takahashi a new classmate and the
so-called master of the wicked I Uther's
dream of having an ordinary highschool
life ends before it can truly begin and
it's all thanks to this eccentric young
girl that drags him down an unwelcome
trip to memory lane looks like the
perfect recipe for some hilarious
comedic madness to me next we have one
of the oh geez a beloved classic of the
mid-2000s Ouran High School Host Club
Han Academy an elaborate and prestigious
high school for rich kids is certainly
not some place you'd expect to find the
plain and unassuming Haruhi Fujioka she
stumbles upon a club room belonging to
the school's host club and seemingly in
faiths attempt to make their first
meeting memorable Haruhi manages to
break an immensely expensive VARs unable
to repay the boys for the vars
Haruhi becomes their errand boy in a
twist she finds herself being promoted
and joining the male hosts just like
that a lovable commoner protagonist gets
thrust headfirst into the world of
elaboration a ngons that provide more
than a fair share of comedy a classic
here over a decade ago all run remains
one of the more popular reverse harm's
out there for those who were around them
if you're looking for a show that gives
you hours of non-stop fun and laughs
consider this one with his lovable
characters and eccentric scenarios or
runs a romantic comedy that you won't
regret picking up
we reached the halfway point with what
that man lives hard for anime fans at
times out there in the world of normies
it's not uncommon for people of this
community to be stigmatized and such
while we often have each other to count
on the same doesn't hold true for now
Rumi mimosa at least at first like a lot
of people not roomies an adult holding a
deep secret she swears to keep a life as
an otaku and a fujiyoshi a secret it
doesn't take long for things to go amiss
as she runs into hirotaka and if Umi a
previous acquaintance
after hearing now Ruby's rant about her
struggling love life hirotaka presents a
brilliant suggestion why not date him as
a fellow otaku surely dating him would
make things a lot easier two of them
right it's not as easy as you think
though thus begins their awkward romance
much like psycho know what taco is a
show that can be enjoyed by everyone and
is entertaining with its colorful
characters and interactions but beyond
it all it's a show that can be fully
enjoyed by those more attuned with otaku
culture then again that's most of us I
guess so I'd suggest you give this one a
shot I seriously think it's underrated
[Music]
at number four on the list we follow geo
story in monthly girls nozaki khan
confessing is certainly one of the
toughest things to do for young students
however when one gets over the hump and
confesses things aren't as simple as
getting yes or no for an answer
just ask lovestruck geo Sakura who finds
the courage to confess to the guy she
likes no Zaki
unfortunately the dense no Zaki who's a
popular shoujo manga artist thinks that
she's a fan of ease and whisks her off
to work as an assistant right off the
bat we're off to a hilarious start but
40 oh this is an opportunity to get
closer to the oblivious guy she's wears
to one day make his heart hers along the
way she gets acquainted with some of the
most colorful characters from school and
no sakis job as a manga artist and while
they don't make Gio's predicament any
easier they create a recipe for surefire
laughs and fun as far as the audience is
concerned
[Music]
and number three we have probably one of
the most influential rom cons before the
start of the 2010s doradora
would we really have a rom-com list
without featuring the show with the
queen of the sundays well one of the
queens but considering they're all
voiced by the same voice actress during
her heyday i guess it doesn't really
make much of a difference does it Dora
Dora tells the story of Ryoji who
despite his appearance is actually one
of the nicest guys around responsible
kind and pretty damn awkward
he's the stark contrast to the feast and
feisty taiga aisaka as fate would have
it the two cross paths in an
unflattering manner discovering each
other secrets Ryoji and taiga get thrust
into working together to help each other
with their respective crushes all seems
to go well until more high jinks
including a pretty transfer student
threatened to complicate things more
importantly how much longer until Ryoji
and Tyga end up falling for each other
in this whole mess
[Music]
plenty of guys dream of entering a
school full of girls but such a dream
ends up being a nightmare for our main
characters in prison school the second
ranked anime on this list circumstances
send five boys into the prestigious
Hachi Mitsu private academy despite
being the situation of many guys dreams
the boys find themselves shunned for
some reason it doesn't take long for a
rude awakening in the form of jail time
after they find themselves caught for
peeping now being the only guys in a
school full of girls doesn't seem like
the best thing in the world now does it
the boys only have each other to stick
to if they want to survive this
torturous experience at the hands of the
school student council will they managed
to get out in one piece
or will they crack under the pressure
watch this hilarious HEC Ruiz to find
out expect no shortage of overreactions
fanservice and awkward comedy this is a
show that doesn't hold back and will
give you one hell of an experience ten
entries ten romantic comedies I want to
know which one your favorite is among
them in case you haven't watched any of
them I think I covered enough bases for
you here to pick something that looks
appealing to you in that case I'd love
to hear from you afterwards animate
shorty shows no shortage of comedies
that come in all flavors and we can
expect to see more of those in the years
to come for now that's got to do it make
sure to LIKE and subscribe if you enjoy
this kind of content and I'll see you
next time for another Vinny tube list
[Music]
you